the issue isn't even so much big versus  small as it is restrained versus  unrestrained limited versus unlimited  the issue isn't so much public versus  private sectors or government versus  business ultimately what this is coming  down to is bounded versus unbounded and  really ultimately what it comes down to  is good versus bad build versus destroy  big business cartels with unlimited  power are in no way preferable to  unchecked power in government in many  ways they're worse in the words of even  cocaine Mitch McConnell the faith of the  business friendly GOP establishment  unrestrained businesses can constitute a  quote  Shadow government even less accountable  to the people than Washington D.C I love  business  but I make no Idol out of business I  love free markets I make no Idol out of  markets